foreign
Matthews in Atlanta hi Matthew welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
all right so
um I want to start off with um big fan
of baby steps um I'm 24 years old
um currently just finished building a
house did a lot of the work myself with
the help of friends and family and was
able to build a house for under two
hundred thousand dollars in this crazy
Market we're in
um but basically I'm at a point with
that project kind of depleted my savings
but I'm starting to have some serious
truck troubles and I know you are
anti-car payment and I'm just trying to
figure out what I kind of need to start
preparing for because it's an old pickup
truck it's got almost 300 000 miles on
it and it leaks oil doesn't have AC it's
just uh it's basically it needs these
tires it just needs a lot of stuff and
it's not it's probably needs more than
the truck is worth all of that was
happening while you were building the
house
yes so why did it now become a dadgum
emergency
well I mean that was happening six
months ago it was leaking oil
yeah six months ago it had 298 000 miles
on it
mm-hmm
so I'm not going to give you permission
to turn it into drama now when you
didn't then
yeah okay what do you make a year
about thirty six thousand
okay
what other debts do you have
um I have some debt to some family
members to help me kind of seal the deal
with getting the house finished in time
um because with all the material rate
increases how much do you owe your
family
uh right at fifty thousand and what's
this house worth about 300
uh no it appraised for five hundred
thousand way to go man congratulations
okay thank you
um
what do you do for a living to make 36
000 a year
for a local property management company
doing maintenance
um so basically we manage rental
properties and I I help fix them when
they break okay good for you
okay two things I would do if I woke up
in your shoes
okay
I was pushing on you because the the
change in the truck is not Material only
the change in your situation
although in other words the truck was
not a crisis before but it became a
crisis now that you finish the house and
you looked up and went oh crap look what
I did
yeah yeah and so uh and you go what if
this thing falls down on me well here's
the thing probably
you've got six months before the thing
lays down
okay but very likely you got three
months would you agree with that okay
yeah because it's just it's just you
just looked up and went this roof looks
bad it's probably going to leak but it's
not yet leaking and that's kind of what
we're doing here so that's the way I'm
analyzing this if I'm missing something
you can you can argue with me that's
okay
um okay the uh so what would I do in
your shoes man you you have a gift in
knowing how to work with your hands and
you can make a lot of money building
decks on the weekends or doing
maintenance handyman work for somebody
on the weekends and I'll bet you you
could pile up five or six thousand bucks
in two or three months side jobs
yeah and I I do have a woodworking
business that I'm kind of in the process
of starting up do you making money
I haven't made it I haven't turned a
profit yet okay I want you to go make
some money to buy it I'm not I'm not
talking about your dreams I want you to
go make some money to buy a truck
okay like a five because you're driving
a two thousand dollar truck we need to
get you into a six or an eight thousand
dollar truck so you need five or six
grand
okay and you need that in the next 90
days and you need to get that as extra
income way to go
and this next truck is not going to be
pretty and people go your buddies in the
construction trade are gonna make fun of
you when you pull up to the seller they
already do though that's right and so
none of that's going to change my fear
is that you got a house now and you
started flexing your muscles a little
bit and you think guys and houses should
drive cars that look like X or Y
oh yeah and I don't want you to start
getting too big for your britches you
owe your family like the way you talked
about how you got into this house I did
it for two hundred thousand dollars and
then you quietly whispered and I had to
go ask Mommy for fifty thousand too
right so there's a little bit of flexing
and a little bit of reality let's do
this all the right way and let's work
like a maniac for the next 12 to 18 to
24 months pay off mom and dad
get yourself a truck that's that you can
rely on and build your business you're
worth more than thirty six thousand
dollars my friend with the skills you've
got yeah you need to be making more
money overall that's a that's a Ken
Coleman thing there but but as far as
what you called about as far as the
truck 90 days
two thousand dollars a month is sixty
six grand sell the truck for two that's
an eight thousand dollar truck that's a
move up that's not a permanent solution
but that keeps you from being left on
the side of the road uh without anything
working you're probably gonna put some
tires on it in the meantime too uh you
know because you might blow a tire that
that's very real I don't know how bad
the tires are you can look at them but
if you can make it four months with the
tires because tires do not increase the
value of a two thousand dollar truck
yep so putting putting a thousand
dollars worth of tires on there it
doesn't solve anything except except
keep you from being stranded so that's
what I would do and the second thing I
would do is I would just run down to the
credit union if you can talk them into
it to loaning you fifty thousand on a
500 000 house fixed rate on a one-year
note and pay it off in one year and go
and pay off mom and dad today yes
because Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you owe your relatives
money
the borrower is slave yes the lender and
it changes relationships and I wouldn't
want that even for a year if I were in
your shoes but if you don't have any
choices then you just do need to do what
John said and roll up your sleeves and
after you get the truck let's go and get
the the family loan cleared after that
so but uh great job 36 Grand sitting in
a half million dollar house almost paid
for he man he Dave he's on a precipice
he is right on that edge where 24 year
olds become 25 26 year olds and he can
look up and owe nobody anything and be a
millionaire and be a millionaire in
short order or he's can also have he
could fall backwards into normal a 2024
F-350 Dually and plus this and plus a
bunch of tools I was more on that than
he does on the house and be a in a mess
he like he's sitting right on that
precipice man you can you can you could
fall off into stupid right here really
easy real easy man yeah from two guys
who did it right yeah this is true and
why did it involve trucks in both of our
cases both of our cases
yeah
we know the type we look at them in the
mirror yeah oh there you go hey nice
call Matthew and overall man I got to
tell you this is pretty impressive 24
years old 50 000 out on five million 500
000 house very impressive very well done
sir but yeah John's right don't fall the
wrong way on this there's a lean up the
hill don't fall back